hey what is up guys I'm Kip EHD here and
I'm here at CES 2014 and here everyone
seems to have a 4k TV Samsung's got one
LG's got one Panasonic's got one even
companies that I didn't know make TVs
have a 4k TV here but what about
shooting 4k what about actually
recording it and getting the whole
system from the camera to the TV doesn't
really matter if you go above 4k I've
seen an 8k TV here already but nothing
shoots 8k so let's take a look at our
four casings here at CES alright now I'm
gonna start in a weird place I'm gonna
start with the Samsung Galaxy Note 3
because if you remember my review of
that this phone has a camera that shoots
4k video but here's the thing about that
the resolution is great and everything
and it is definitely 4k but the Galaxy
Note 3 still has a pretty small sensor
compared to those dedicated cameras it's
just a phone and the 4k video it shoots
is also at a slightly lower bit rate
than the 4k from dedicated cameras and
all this basically means a little bit
lower density of information now it
still takes up plenty of space more than
1080p footage as you can see by the live
counter in the upper right hand corner
of the frame but it kind of falls apart
with any real shaky movement but hey
that's a start and it looks great on 4k
displays much better than 1080p video
and this phone starts at around 600
bucks off contract now a big part of CES
as we know is starting off this
ridiculous new technology that may seem
crazy at first but that hopefully comes
down in price over the coming months and
years so now that we've seen all these
4k TVs at last year's CES and we're even
seeing 4k monitors now we're gonna start
to see more 4k cameras this time around
but their prices and convenience for the
regular person are still a bit much but
this is CES so we can take that with a
grain of salt
take the Canon booth for example they
didn't have anything new to show in the
4k stuff but they have their existing 4k
solutions on display at a Canon c500 and
the canon 1dc the c500 is a great
example of what i'm talking about when i
say it's not convenient to shoot 4k
right now the thing is a beast with a
beast of a lens to match do not look up
the price tag at this lens unless you're
sitting down but anyway the c500 will
shoot 4k but not to internal store
you need a second and external recorder
that can record 60 frames per second
through a single cable or 120 frames per
second over a pair of HD SDI cables but
just look at how much gear you need here
on this camera to shoot 4k it is
incredible quality and its massive
dynamic range and very high bitrate but
this setup you're looking at right here
hopefully you're sitting down is over
forty thousand dollars the canon 1dc
though is a DSLR that shoots 4k video
with a full-frame sensor and it's
probably the most reasonable really high
quality 4k option for a lot of people to
consider shooting with it takes SD cards
it shoots 4k at 24 frames per second but
still just the body of this camera
without this awesome glass will cost you
twelve thousand dollars but i also
visited the Sony booth today as you guys
told me to do on Twitter and there were
some slightly more interesting options
of course they have their current fs700
no surprise it's a great camera but it
can only shoot 4k when you add a massive
recorder to the back it doesn't shoot 4k
internally so that makes it a huge and
also slightly more expensive over $9,000
4k shooting setup but they also had a
slightly smaller 4k camera that we've
seen on Amazon actually for a bit and
it's a bit easier to hold on the fs700 a
little bit more compact more ergonomic
and a few people are already shooting
with it and it records 4k at 60 frames
per second to internal storage so you
don't need any extra cables or fancy
recorders or anything but it's still a
bit steep at five thousand dollars
but at CES sony has introduced this this
is the first 4k sony handycam so the
handycam line as we know is already
famous for putting the best video
quality in the palm of the hand and
being extremely easy to shoot with so
this is actually interesting that's the
combo we're looking for now it has a one
inch sensor so the same size as my
pocket camera the rx100 in fact I think
they said it was the same sensor so it's
a bit small and that may sacrifice
dynamic range or a little bit of
low-light performance but it's putting
4k video shooting in a compact and easy
to use format that's a balance that's
been really hard to strike and it keeps
the price a bit lower than the other
options we've looked at and it's going
to start supposedly at $2,000 now it's
no Galaxy Note 3 price but it's way
better than Galaxy Note 3
quality and Sonia is really proud of
this and I think it's a great first step
towards a ton of people starting to
shoot 4k video to catch up with all
these crazy fancy 4k TVs we have
[Music]